a las vegas man hoping somebody will
step up after a string of recent home
invasions in a summerlin community mary
jane bellies alive in that area with the
homeowner's plea to try to catch these
thieves
the homeowner who lives here in the
summerlin area community of
the gardens he says that he wants
neighbors and businesses to be more
vigilant about these recent break-ins so
it doesn't happen to you
that's where they came over richard
doyle says it was broad daylight when
burglars hopped the wall to his home
smashed the back door to get into his
bedroom to steal valuables like jewelry
his truck and guns doyle says his home
wasn't the only target police told him
his house was the fourth break-in in the
gardens community in the past six weeks
doyle says he wants other homeowners to
take this as a learning lesson to
protect your home and valuables like
installing a security system and making
it difficult for thieves to enter your
home i implore
anyone with any information
with regards to
this
these happenings in henderson and in
summerland and probably all over las
vegas they come forward and give the
police as much information
as they possibly can
because it is an unforgivable thing to
break into a house because you feel
violated doyle says while police were
able to locate his stolen truck and
return it to him he hopes his other
items will also be found
now doyle did file a police report with
metro if you have any information you're
asked to call crime stoppers that's at
summerlin mary 702-385-5555 ballaza live
local now